shishun knight pulliam happily shows off  her baby bump  despite drama surrounding her recent  split from husband ed Hartwell I'm so  excited about just celebrating her from  this point forward it's not about any of  this I'm putting this behind me  it's a bro it's about celebrating her  also this week Keyshia posted an  encouraging quote to her Instagram I'm  actually grateful that some things  didn't work out the way I wanted them to  have you seen him or spoken to him after  the divorce filing on Monday after he  told you Mindy there's nothing to say  there's nothing to say at this point  last month Hartwell filed for divorce  from Keyshia just days after she  announced she was pregnant the two were  married for nearly as seven months I'm  not about dragging people through the  mud in the media of even with the  paternity test one day he will have to  answer back and explained her